After they land a role in a movie, actors
always look for anything they can do to ensure
they deliver the best performance they can.
Whether it’s physical training, getting
lost in a character’s psyche, or studying
up on history, there are several methods they
turn to.
But sometimes, it’s as simple as getting
a drink or two.
Some of Hollywood’s biggest films feature
sequences that involve intoxicated thespians.
Here are 10 actors who got drunk to film their
scenes.
Natalie Portman and Mila Kunis
In one of the most talked-about sequences
in 2010, Portman and Kunis did a love scene
together in the awards contender, Black Swan.
It was new territory for the two actresses,
and they needed a little liquid courage before
filming.
Director Darren Aronofsky has said that his
stars shared a bottle of tequila to calm their
nerves.
Kunis has denied this claim, but others on-set
have confirmed alcohol was involved.
In the end, Portman won an Oscar for her performance,
and Kunis received much acclaim, so it seems
like it was worth it.
Robert Shaw
Shark hunter Quint is perhaps the most memorable
character in Jaws thanks to his eccentric
personality and one fantastic monologue he
delivers while on board the Orca.
Quint tells Brody and Hooper the story of
the U.S.S.
Indianapolis and the horrifying shark attack
the crew endured.
Shaw thought it would be for the best to shoot
the scene drunk, since it called for the characters
to be drinking at night.
However, he was too inebriated and as a result,
nothing could be used from the takes.
Regretting what transpired, Shaw asked Steven
Spielberg for another try later that night,
and delivered the speech as seen in the film.
Julie Andrews
Somewhat surprisingly, Andrews admitted that
she was drunk while performing the “Do-Re-Mi”
sequence in The Sound of Music.
The farmer that owned the land near where
they were filming brewed his own schnapps
in a barn, which Andrews would frequent when
she practiced her guitar.
She kept taking shots as the day went on,
and by the time it was ready to film, Andrews
was fairly hammered.
Not only does this add a whole new layer to
a famous song, it also illustrates the actress’
supreme talent at her craft.
Watching it, nobody can tell what’s going
on.
Brad Pitt and Edward Norton
Some off set drinking led to a famous bit
in Fight Club.
During their downtime, Pitt and Norton got
a little drunk and started hitting golf balls
in an attempt to whack the catering truck.
Director David Fincher began filming them
and gave the two actors some lines to create
a whole new scene for the movie.
The result was a humorous moment that highlighted
the pair’s chemistry and the character’s
growing friendship.
It wouldn’t be surprising if alcohol was
used to capture some more of this drama’s
best scenes, but this is the only reported
instance.
Johnny Depp
Depp returned to the world of Hunter S. Thompson
in The Rum Diary, and aptly made sure he had
plenty of alcohol to do the job right.
While filming the movie, Depp and his director
Bruce Robinson kept a bottle of Chivas Regal
close by.
Apparently, Depp liked to treat himself to
the drink rather liberally, which resulted
in him being drunk for portions of the finished
product.
Though critics and audiences didn’t take
too kindly to Rum Diary, the consensus was
that Depp’s performance was typically great,
so it’s safe to say the actor tried his
best.
Billy Bob Thornton
Not your usual Christmas movie, Bad Santa
earned itself a passionate following due to
its extremely vulgar content.
The star of the madness is Thornton as an
alcoholic department store Santa, who clearly
is not the right fit for the job.
It shouldn’t come as a shock then, that
Thornton has admitted he frequently got drunk
during principal photography in an attempt
to better portray the character.
His methods worked, and Bad Santa went on
to become a rude and crude holiday classic.
With a sequel on the horizon, it’ll be interesting
to see if Thornton gets hammered for Santa
again.
Shia LaBeaouf
The drama Lawless is set during the Prohibition
era and focuses on three brothers running
a bootlegging business, so alcohol played
a heavy role in the narrative.
It was also a major tool for star Shia LaBeaouf,
who got drunk off of moonshine every day to
get into character.
Unfortunately, he got very intoxicated, and
his behavior upset his co-stars.
Mia Wasikowska took greatest offense, trying
to quit the movie due to her discomfort.
Maybe someone should have stepped in and told
Shia that there are other ways to act drunk
than to actually be plastered.
Bob Hoskins and John Leguizamo
Super Mario Bros. is widely considered as
one of the worst films ever made.
That’s an opinion not lost on its two stars,
who quickly realized that the quality was
not up to par when they were filming.
In an effort to make their job more fun, Hoskins
and Leguizamo would drink scotch between takes
and did some scenes drunk.
One in particular caused harm to Hoskins.
While driving a van, Leguizamo broke too hard
and slammed the door on his co-star’s hand.
As a result, Hoskins had to wear a cast for
portions of production, which is visible in
the film.
Martin Sheen
The troubled production of Apocalypse Now
is well documented, and just reading about
it can stress somebody out.
For the people working on it, it was all kinds
of hell and lead to heavy amounts of drinking.
Star Sheen took part in this, most famously
for the opening scene in the hotel room.
He got drunk right before filming and told
Francis Ford Copolla to roll the cameras.
Sheen’s performance here set the tone for
an intense ride, as he punched a mirror, started
weeping, and almost attacked Copolla off-camera.
It’s tough to watch at times, but there’s
no denying it’s a great moment.
Margot Robbie
Robbie’s big breakthrough came as Naomi,
Jordan Belfort’s wife in The Wolf of Wall
Street.
The film is a celebration of excess, and features
a ton of explicit content – including numerous
sex scenes.
Robbie is in a few of these herself, and she
was nervous to bare it all on camera to film
with Leonardo DiCaprio.
To calm herself down, Robbie said she took
three shots of tequila before shooting the
first one.
It definitely paid off, as the actress stole
the show and became a household name.
The chemistry between her and Leo was electric
and made Wolf stand out.
Those are our picks for actors that got drunk
before filming their scenes.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!